AHEAD AND GET STARTED WITH THE
COMMITTEE A HEARING TODAY IS
YOU'LL SEE WE'RE QUITE A BIT
SHY OF A QUORUM SO WILL BE
STARTING THIS A SUBCOMMITTEE
TODAY JUST WANNA MAKE A COUPLE
OF ANNOUNCEMENTS. THE A TWO
BILLS BEFORE US TODAY AND WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW THE TIME LIMIT
OF TEN MINISTRY SIDE FOR BOTH
BILLS ADDITIONALLY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AFTER THAT TESTIMONY
WILL BE ASKED JUST FOR THEIR
NAME IN ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE AND NO
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY THERE. ARE
THERE ARE NO BILLS PROPOSE FOR
CONSENT AND SEEN THAT SENATOR
RUBIO IS HERE WHICH LIKE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU
. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE FIRST TODAY ON GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT TO AT THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTE MANUFACTURERS TO
SUBMIT A PHYSICAL DESCRIPTION
AND PHOTOGRAPH OF EACH TYPE OF
DEVICE THEY WILL SELL UP TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
IMPOSE A REASONABLE FEE ON
MANUFACTURERS TO COVER THE
DEPARTMENTS COST AT THAT
MINISTERING THIS PROGRAM
DESPITE LAWS PROHIBITING THE
SALE OF ELECTRONIC CIRCUIT
CIGARETTES TO PEOPLE UNDER
TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD. THEIR USE
HAS RAPIDLY BEEN INCREASING WE
ARE SEEN DEVICES ON THE MARKET
THEY LOOK LIKE USB FLASH DRIVES
EVEN PENS COMMON OBJECTS THAT
EASILY GO UNDETECTED. AS A
FORMER EDUCATOR I CAN TELL YOU
THAT TODD THESE DEVICES ARE
VERY DIFFICULT TO TACT
ESPECIALLY THAT THEY'RE- USING
ITEMS THAT RESEMBLE CLASSROOM
EVERYDAY ITEMS. BY WAY OF
EXAMPLE WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT
LOOKS LIKE A HIGHLIGHTER FOR
ANY TEACHER OUT THERE. WE HAVE
A PENCIL CASE THAT TYPICALLY
OUR KIDS KEEP LEAD IN. AND SOLD
TODAY I FIND THIS TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT AT
LEAST OUR TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S OUT THERE AND WHAT TO
LOOK FOR. SO ACCORDING TO THE
REPORT RELEASED BY THE UNITED
STATES FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. MORE THAN
THREE POINT SIX MILLION MIDDLE
AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
REPORTED USING THESE DEVICES
WITHIN THE PAST THIRTY DAYS.
THIS IS AN INCREASE FROM ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION STUDENTS AS
THE PREVIOUS YEARS. THIS MAKES
IT INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT FOR
PARENTS AND EDUCATORS ONCE
AGAIN TO IDENTIFY THESE
OBJECTS. ARE WITH ME TODAY IS
MEGAN FORD A RECENT HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE AND LEXI. I CAN NOW
LEE WHO ARE HERE TO TESTIFY ON
MY BEHALF THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. A GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LEXI OPTIONALLY I AM AN
INCOMING SENIOR OUT RIO
AMERICANO HIGH SCHOOL AND PROUD
TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT SENATOR
RUBIO SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT I HAVE EXPERIENCE WITH
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES AND IT
TOOK E OVER A YEAR OF TRYING
TO QUIT TO FULLY STOP MY
EVERYDAY USE EVER SINCE I HAVE
STOPPED THE USE OF ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES I'VE NOTICED HOW
THEY'VE WE'VE THEMSELVES INTO
THE SOCIAL LIVES OF ALL OF MY
PEERS. AT SCHOOL I SEE
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES
CONSTANTLY WITH STUDENTS USING
THEM IN THE BATHROOM PASSING
THEM AROUND AT LUNCH AND EVEN
DURING CLASS WHEN THE TEACHERS
BACK TO BACK IS TURNED AWAY
FROM THEM THERE IS A FALSEHOOD
ASSUMES BY TEENS THAT THESE
ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES ARE
HARMLESS THIS FALSEHOOD WAS
TOLD TO BE TOLD TO ME BY MY
PEERS WHEN I WAS A FRESHMAN IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND INSPIRED ME TO
TRY TO USE ONE FOR THE FIRST
TIME. I WAS QUICKLY ADDICTED
AND WAS EASILY ABLE TO HIDE IT
FROM MY TEACHERS AND PARENTS AS
I COULD COMFORTABLY KEEP IT IN
MY POCKET. I COULD EASILY AND
DISCREETLY USE IT WILL MY
PARENTS WERE HOME. AND WAS EVEN
ABLE TO CHARGE IT WHILE THEY
WERE IN THE SAME ROOM AS ME. IT
WAS THE FIRST THING I THOUGHT
OF WHEN I WOKE UP IN THE
MORNING AND THE LAST THING I
DID BEFORE GOING TO BED. I WAS
AN ADDICT. I STOP USING MONTHS
AGO. BUT NOW I SEE NEW DESIGNS
AND DEVICES PASSED AROUND BY MY
PEERS AT SCHOOL THAT I DON'T
EVEN RECOGNIZE. THESE COMPANIES
ARE CREATING NEW DESIGNS SO
RAPIDLY TO KEEP KIDS ATTRACTED
TO THE IDEA OF HAVING THEIR OWN
STYLISH DEVICE. AND KEEPING
THEM ADDICTED TO NICOTINE AND
MARIJUANA. THESE DEVICES ARE SO
DISCREET CONVENIENT AND EASILY
ACCESSIBLE FOR TEENS TO USE
THAT WE NEED PARENTS AND
EDUCATORS TO. BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY THESE DEVICES. IN
ORDER TO STOP. IN ORDER TO HELP
STOP TEENS FROM EXPERIENCE IN A
LIFELONG ADDICTION. THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW PARENTS AND
EDUCATORS TO HAVE A RELIABLE
SOURCE TO EDUCATE THEMSELVES ON
WHAT THESE DEVICES LOOK LIKE
AND EXACTLY WHAT TO LOOK FOR.
AS THESE DEVICES ARE EASILY
MISTAKEN FOR EVERYDAY
ELECTRONICS IT IS CRUCIAL WE
GIVE ADULTS THE PICTURES AND
DESCRIPTIONS OF THESE DEVICES
SO THEY HAVE THE RESOURCE TRY
IDENTIFY THESE ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES AND HELP TEENAGERS
WITH ADDICTION. THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN MY
NAME IS MEGAN FORD I'M A NEWLY
GRADUATED SENIOR FROM RARE
AMERICANO HIGH SCHOOL AND I'M
PROUD TO BE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR RUBIO.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE WITH ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES AS WELL AS WHAT I'VE
LEARNED ABOUT THEM. A FEW YEARS
AGO I DIDN'T KNOW ANYONE MY AGE
TO USE ELECTRONIC TOBACCO
PRODUCTSNO WHAT I'VE EVER
CONSIDERED USING ONE MYSELF. I
BECAME FAMILIAR WITH THE NEWER
SPEAKER VAPES ABOUT A YEAR AGO
WHEN A FRIEND TAUGHT ME HOW TO
ONE HELL TO GET A HEAD RUSH OR
A BUZZ FROM HIS BREEZES FIRE.
THIS WAS A TINY METALLIC BOX
THAT FIT IN THEIR HANDS AND WAS
DISCREET ENOUGH TO HEAD IN
CROWDED RESTAURANTS WITH THEIR
PARENTS THE NEXT ROOM AND
EVENTUALLY EVEN DURING CLASS.
IT HONESTLY DID SEEM HARMLESS
REST OF THE TIME AND IT TAKES
OF THAT GREEN APPLE. WHAT I
DIDN'T REALIZE BACK THEN WAS
THAT EVEN THOUGH THE CHEMICALS
IN TORRANCE CIGARETTES MAY NOT
EXISTING PAGES. MOST BRANDS
WHICH IS STILL CONTAINS
CARCINOGEN. CARCINOGENIC
SUBSTANCES AS WELL AS
INCREDIBLY CONCENTRATED ABOUT
SOME NICOTINE THAT I GOT
ADDICTED TO VERY QUICKLY. I
DIDN'T REALIZE OF THE RUSH I
THOUGHT WAS DUE TO NICOTINE
INCREASING MY JOB MADE AN
INTERNAL LEVELS MY PRIDE
PRESSURE BLOOD PRESSURE AND MY
HEART RATE. AND I CERTAINLY
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THAT I WOULD
EVENTUALLY NEED AFFECTS IN
ORDER FOR MY BODY AND BRAIN TO
FUNCTION NORMALLY. THERE'S SO
MUCH WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
AFFECTS OF THE CIGARETTES AND
WITH THE CONCENTRATE ACTION OF
NEW AND MORE DISCRETE DEVICES
SOME DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THEY
LOOK LIKE. I BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL WOULD HELP EDUCATE THE
GENERAL PUBLIC MORE
SPECIFICALLY TEACHERS AND
PARENTS ON WHAT TO LOOK FOR IN
THEIR CLASSROOMS AND HOMES.
PUTTING DESCRIPTIONS AND PHOTOS
OF EVERYDAY DEVICE ON THE
MARKET AND SENDING THIS
INFORMATION OUT TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
HELP EDUCATORS AND PARENTS
REALIZE WHAT EXACTLY THEIR KIDS
ARE USING. AND TAKES STEPS TO
HELP THE KIDS REALIZE WHAT
USING WILL DO TO THEM. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND ASK YOUR
AYE THE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. YEAH YEAH NOW AWESOME
KIND OF PRODUCT DAYS FOR THANK
YOU. WORKING CARVE A WHOLE WITH
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. SORRY I'M A GROUP
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. KELLY
BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS AND
SUPPORT. JAMES OPTIONALLY A
PARENT OF A STUDENT REAL
AMERICAN HIGH SCHOOL I'M IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
IT IS FOR A TICKET TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION WHEN YOU
HAVE A QUORUM SOMEONE ELSE THE
SECRETARY CALLED ROLE WHAT HERE
MAYES HERE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BIGELOW BONTA BURKE CARRILLO
LARA THE MCCARTY NAZARIAN RAMOS
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON. WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM SO THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. SEE NO ONE I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE QUICKER
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE ON THE BILL.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
RAMOS A SECOND BY MISTER
BIGELOW ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE. I DO HAVE A BUY ONE
QUESTION SURE THAT IS.
CONSIDERING THE RAPID. THE
INCREASE IN THE WAY THESE THESE
PRODUCTS ARE DISGUISED SO TO
SPEAK IT DOES YOUR DOES YOUR
BILL ANTICIPATE TIME FRAMES
FROM WHICH MANUFACTURERS HAVE
TO HAVE TO REPORT THESE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH I
BECAUSE I BUT IT'S THERE I
MISSED IT I APOLOGIZE NO WORD
RIGHT NOW I CURRENTLY AM IN
TALKS WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS
JUST TO SEE WHAT THEIR
CAPABILITY IS BUT WE HAVE HOPE
RIGHT NEXT YEAR WE CAN RELATE A
NEXT NEXT WEEK. AND SO WE'RE
WAITING ON THEM TELL US WHAT'S
FEASIBLE. WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS SOON AS COME
OUT THAT ALL THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE INFORMATION ON
IT. GREAT GREAT OKAY THANK YOU.
THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND WHICH I TO CLOSE
CENTER. YES THANK YOU ONE OF
THE OTHER. I DON'T WANT TO PUT
OUT THERE IS THAT IT CLEARLY
IT'S A GROWING EPIDEMIC BUT-
NOW THEY'RE USING THE DEVICES
TO PUT. MARIJUANA LIQUIDS IN
THERE AND NOW THEY'RE- USING
OTHER OF FINDING OTHER WAYS OF
USING THESE DEVICES SO THAT'S
ANOTHER ISSUE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO CONTEND WITH IN THE FUTURE
BUT MARIJUANA NOW IT'S BECOMING
ONE OF THEM. THE KOREAN MY
BIGGEST PROBLEM FOR OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THEY'RE USING
THESE DEVICES SO. YOU KNOW
WE'LL CIRCLE BACK IN THE NEAR
FUTURE AND SEE WE CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT AS WELL
THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY. MISTER RAMOS A
SECOND BY MISTER BIGELOW THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES. MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGAR CURRY I
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BURKE CAREER. CARILLO AYE FLORA
FLORA AYE LIMóN. MCCARTY I IN
THIS AREA RAMOS ROSS I
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON.
EIGHT SO WE HAVE EIGHT VOTES
THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT OF
COMMITTEE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON.
THANK YOU FOR. HAVING THIS
AFTERNOON. SEVEN RIGHT. WE HAVE
BEFORE US ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
THIRTY NINE. ASK IF YOU ACCEPT
THE MINUTES BEFORE WE MOVE A
BILL IS. THAT'S AMENDED. PLEASE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LET
ME BEGIN THE SEVENTY BY
CLARIFYING THE AMENDMENTS THE
AUTHORS. OF AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
NINE ARE ACCEPTING TODAY
INCLUDING MYSELF THE FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF LIKE TRONIC
CIGARETTES AS INCLUDED.
FLAVORED E. LIQUIDS IN PODS
WHETHER WITHOUT NICOTINE
REQUIRE RETAILERS TO CHECK AND
VERIFY ID FOR EVERY SALE.
STRIKE DUPLICATIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND FINALLY STRIKE
SECTION SEVEN OF THE BILL
DEALING WITH THE SALE OF
FLAVORED E. CIGARETTES. WHILE I
PERSONALLY BELIEVE AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY NINE ALREADY STRIKES THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
ALLOWING ADULTS TO MAKE THEIR
OWN DECISIONS IN COMBATING
UNDERAGE USE MANY MEMBERS BOTH
OF THIS COMMITTEE. OUR BODY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS
FEEL OTHERWISE. IN MY OWN
COMMITTEE I ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS
WHICH REMOVED PENALTIES FOR
YOUTH CAUGHT POSSESSION DESPITE
MY PERSONAL BELIEF THAT TEENS
NEED TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR THEIR DECISIONS. HOWEVER
THIS ISSUE IS TOO IMPORTANT TO
ALLOW IDEOLOGICAL PURITY TO
STAND IN THE WAY OF PROGRESS
AND WE HAD MUCH DISCUSSION IN
OUR COMMITTEE ABOUT THAT. IT IS
IN THAT SPIRIT THAT TODAY WE
WILL ACCEPT THESE AMENDMENTS AS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IN ADDITION
WE WILL TAKE IN AUTHORS
AMENDMENT TO CORRECT A DRAFTING
AIR. WHICH EXCLUDED HOOKAH FROM
THE DEFINITION OF THE CIGARETTE
AS IS CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
LAW MIXTURE. I HAVE ALSO HAD
CONVERSATIONS SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT CLARIFYING THE
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE DOES NOT.
REPEAT MYSELF DOES NOT PREEMPT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR IMPOSING
E. CIGARETTE FLAVOR BANDS OR
OTHER SALES RESTRICTIONS WE
AGREED THIS MORNING NOT TO
INCLUDE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE ON
PREEMPTION GIVEN THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BEING ADOPTED HERE.
TODAY BUT I'M HAPPY TO STATE
FOR THE RECORD THAT IS NOT OUR
INTENT WITH THIS BILL TO
PREEMPT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
EFFORTS. WITH ALL THAT SAID AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE IS THE
PRODUCT OF MONTHS OF
CONVERSATION COMPRADOR
COMPROMISED REMEMBERS THIS
BODY. THE BILL BEFORE US TODAY
PROHIBITS VAPING COMPETITION
ADVERTISING USING PACKAGING
THOSE ATTRACTED TO KIDS
INCLUDING BANNING THE USE OF
CARTOON MASCOTS IN PACKAGING
RESEMBLING CANDY. THE BILL
RAMPS UP PENALTIES ON RETAILERS
AND STRAW PURCHASERS TO PROVIDE
THESE PRODUCTS TO KIDS AND
REQUIRES THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CONDUCTS STING
OPERATIONS AT RETAIL SITES
REPRESENTING NO LESS THAN
TWENTY PERCENT. OF THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF LICENSED TOBACCO
RETAILERS. THE BILL ALSO
IMPOSES MORE STRINGENT AGE
VERIFICATION REQUIREMENTS ON
TOBACCO SALES AND PROHIBITS
ANYONE UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE FROM ENTERING A TOBACCO
SHOP. AB SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE
REPRESENTS A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH TO CLOSE YOUTH ACCESS
POINTS INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY
IS FOR THOSE THAT VIOLATE THE
LAW RESTRICT EXPOSURE TO THESE
PRODUCTS AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONTINUED
OVERSIGHT AND EDUCATION ON THE
ISSUE. THE BILL REMAINS A WORK
IN PROGRESS AS EVIDENCED BY THE
MEMBERS WE'RE TAKING HERE TODAY
BUT THIS REMAINS A GOOD BILL.
WHEN THIS BILL WAS HEARD
ASSEMBLY GEO ONE OF THE
WITNESSES WHO SPOKE IN FAVOR
WAS A SOPHOMORE.FROM MODESTO
HIGH SCHOOL IN MY DISTRICT AND
AFTER HER EXPERIENCE TESTIFYING
IN COMMITTEE SHE WROTE AN OP ED
FOR THE MODESTO BEE DETAILING
HER EXPERIENCE. I'D LIKE TO
CLOSE MY COMMENTS USING HER
WORDS. COMPROMISE IS ESSENTIAL
TO QUICK LEGISLATIVE REFORM
THAT'S INTERPRETERS IS TOO
RESTRICTIVE OR NOT RESTRICTIVE
ENOUGH JUST WILL PASS THIS BILL
STRIKE A GOOD COMPROMISE.
MEMBERS THIS IS A PERFECT BILL
AND THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK BROUGH. IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED DIDN'T. MOVED AND
SECONDED OKAY WITH BRIDGET THE
A TO Z. AS A MOTIONS AND
SECONDS MISTER. THERE'S A BUNCH
OF A SO. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN LINE WITH THE ENTHUSIASM
I'LL BE BRIEF MORNING CARVEL
HALL WITH THAT CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL. SIXTEEN
THIRTY NINE AND REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE WORK THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS DONE TO
ESTABLISH AN EFFECTIVE TOBACCO
CONTROL MEASURE TO REDUCE
CONSUMPTION OF VPOR PRODUCTS
AMONG YOUTH. SEEM AS LONG
SUPPORTED REDUCING YOUTH ACCESS
AND EXPOSURE TO TOBACCO
PRODUCTS AS NICOTINE IS NOT
ONLY AND HIGHLY ADDICTIVE BUT
HARMFUL TO ADOLESCENT BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT IMPACTED IMPACTS
ATTENTION LEARNING ANDMEMORY.
FROM 201-722-0182 YOUTH
CONSUMPTION OF ELECTRONICAL
CITY ELECTRONIC SIGNATURE TO
INCREASE BY 78% AMONG HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS. AND 48% AMONG
MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENTS. IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT MORE THAN THREE
POINT SIX MILLION U. S. YOUTH
CURRENTLY USE EASE CIGARETTES
AT THROUGHOUT THEIR LIVES THESE
INDIVIDUALS WILL HAVE INCREASED
RISK OF DEVELOPING A TOBACCO
RELATED DISEASE. INCLUDING
CANCER LUNG DISEASE HEART
DISEASE AND STROKE. AS THE
MARKET FOR A CIGARETTES AND-
AND THE EVIDENCE OF THE RISK
ASSOCIATED WITH EASE A GREAT
USE HAS GROWN SO HAS PHYSICIANS
DESIRE TO ENSURE APPROPRIATE
REGULATION OF THEM. AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY NINE TAKES IMPORTANT AND
MEASURED STEPS TOWARD REDUCING
YOUR CONSUMPTION OF THESE PART
OF THESE PRODUCTS BY INCREASING
ENFORCEMENT AND PENALTIES ON
SALES TO MINORS. AND BY
PROHIBITING THE PACKAGING THAT
IS ATTRACTIVE TO YOU. SEE ME
WILL CONTINUE TO REMAIN ENGAGED
IN THE ONGOING DISCUSSIONS ON
TOBACCO CONTROL AND IS
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S POLICIES CONTINUE
TO MOVE THE NEEDLE. ON REDUCING
CONSUMPTION OF THESE HARMFUL
PRODUCTS TODAY WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT AND URGE YOU TO GO
AYE ON SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU OTHERS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CRAIG CAMPBELL ON
BEHALF OF TOBACCO FREE KIDS
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR THE
COMMITTEE STAFF THE CHAIRMEN ON
WORK ON THESE AMENDMENTS WITH
THAT WE HAVE MOVED FROM A
POSITION OF OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO SUPPORT AS PROPOSED
TO BE. AMENDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU. TIM GIVES AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY CANCER ACTION NETWORK
ALSO IN SUPPORT AS PROPOSED TO
BE AMENDED WISHES THINK THE
CHAIR COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE
OTHER. THANK YOU. KELLY BROOKS
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
WERE IN SUPPORT. JAMIE MORGAN
WITH THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS AMENDMENTS AND
THE COMMITTEE OR AND HAVE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL NOW AS IT'S
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED. THANK
YOU. STORY MICHAEL CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION WANTED THANK
THE CHAIR AND THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING TOGETHER ON THIS
APPRECIATE THE AMENDS AND
APPRECIATE. THE AUTHOR
STATEMENT OF CLARIFICATION ON
THE PREEMPTION ISSUE WE'RE
TAKING THE MAN'S BACK TO ARE
COUNSELED TO FORMALLY APPROVE
THE CHANGE IN POSITION BUT THE
AMENDMENTS AS- WRITTEN UP IN
THE ANALYSIS TO SATISFY OUR
CONCERNS AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANY WORKING WITH US THE ONE IN
OPPOSITION. YOUR MEMBERS ALL
THIS WILL BE BRIEF JONATHON
FELDMAN WITH THE VAPOR
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE ARE
STILL OPPOSED EVEN WITH THE
AMENDMENTS. WANT TO START BY
SAYING THAT THERE'S A LOT IN
THE BILL THAT WE AGREE WITH
THAT'S COMMENDABLE THAT WE
THINK DOES ADDRESS THE YOUTH
ACCESS ISSUE BUT- SOME OF THE
MARKETING STANDARDS ARE
AMBIGUOUS AND VAGUE. WILL BE
VERY DIFFICULT FOR MEMBERS TO
FOLLOW SOME OF THE PENALTIES
ARE EXORBITANTLY HIGH EVEN
COMPARED TO OTHER INDUSTRIES IN
THE SAME SPACE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE STILL POSSIBLE.
IF IS THERE ANY ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. SEE NUMBER BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. HI I HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS BUT BEFORE I
STARS WENT TO THE KNOWLEDGE
THIS IS BEEN WORK IN PROGRESS
BY MANY INDIVIDUALS LEGISLATORS
ON BOTH. SIDE OF THE ISLAND
BOTH HOUSES AND WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THERE'S AN-
EPIDEMIC WE SEE IT IN OUR- SEE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE SEE THE
RESEARCH. A FEW MONTHS AGO WITH
OUR LITTLE GIRLS SELLING GIRL
SCOUT COOKIES AT SAFEWAY JUST
ON THE STREET. AND MY TEN YEAR
OLD DAUGHTERS AS ZERO SUM WAS
WALKING OUT THEY SAID WELL THAT
E. CIGARETTES WITHOUT A
CIGARETTE AND- YEAH IT SMELLS
REALLY GOOD THAT'S A LOOK AT IT
IT SMELLS LIKE IT'S PRETTY
TASTY TOO. AND SO LITTLE KIDS
WHO ARE SAYING THIS AND THE
ROMANTICIZE ABOUT THE COOLNESS
OF IT THE FLAVOR. AND SO IT IS
A TRUE EPIDEMIC AND WE DON'T
KNOW THE IMPACTS YET THIS JUST
REPORTS THIS WEEK ABOUT THESE
LONG. AND ISSUES AND
INDIVIDUALS AND IT'S A MYSTERY
A LONG ELEMENT SO. MAYBE MANY
YEARS BEFORE WE ACTUALLY KNOW
THE IMPACT WE KNOW RIGHT NOW
THAT IT'S A PROBLEM SO I
APPLAUD THE EFFORTS GOING HERE
TODAY. AND ONE THING THAT WE
DIDN'T HEAR TOO MUCH ABOUT WHAT
IF YOU COULD TALK ABOUT. MISTER
GRAY IS WHEN YOU AND I MET WITH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
AND- OUR OFFICIALS WITH
DEPARTMENT ABOUT CALLING
BEVERAGE CONTROL. YOU KNOW WE
SOUGHT SENSUALLY TO PASS AND SO
FOR PEOPLE THAT. WHO SELL
ALCOHOL THEIR ESTABLISHMENTS
AND- THEY SLIP UP THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE SEVERE. THE
INABILITY TO SELL THEIR
PRODUCTS THE MONETARY FINE AND
THE LOSS OF YOUR LICENSE WHICH
IS A LIVELIHOOD AND TOBACCO
REAL TO RETAILERS WASN'T SO.
AND THEN CONVERSELY WE SAW THAT.
IN THE IN THE STING REPORTS
RECENTLY THE MAJORITY OF THE
BAD ACTORS WERE. SOME OF THESE
YOU KNOW YOU KNOW NOT THE
TRADITIONAL RETAILERS SOME OF
THESE KIND MONTH POT TYPE
CONVENIENCE STORES AND SO THAT
WAS CONCERNING SO. MAYBE CAN
SPEND A FEW MOMENTS TALKING
ABOUT. THERE'S A NAME IT'S BACK
AND FORTH AND I'M NOT QUITE
SURE MAYBE CAN LIGHTEN US ON
WHAT IS STILL THERE WHAT WE'RE
DOING. WITH THE ENFORCEMENT
PIECE WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION OUR FIRST PARTY THE-
YOU KNOW AS YOU'RE WELL AWARE
AS AS AN AUTHOR OF THE BILL IN
THIS SPACE EARLIER IN THE YEAR
WHEN I HAD SEVERAL BILLS BEFORE
THE JOKE COMMITTEE WE SAT DOWN
WITH ALL THE AUTHORS MASTER
GOING TO PARTICIPATE IN A
WORKING GROUP OVER SEVERAL
MONTHS TO DIVE INTO THE ISSUE.
OF THIS YOUTH EPIDEMIC AS IT
RELATES TO YOU CIGARETTES AND
PART OF THAT PROCESS WAS
LOOKING AT ENFORCEMENT WITH A
FINE TOOTH COMB AND I THINK THE
TAKE AWAY FOR MANY THE MEMBERS
PERHAPS INCLUDING YOURSELF WAS
THAT IT WASN'T AN AREA OF
STRENGTH ARE ENFORCEMENT.
MECHANISMS AS RELATES TO
TOBACCO IN GENERAL RIGHT
CLEARLY A LOT OF. YOU KNOW
PUBLIC HEALTH EDUCATION HAD
BEEN EMPHASIZED IN THE SPACE
BUT A LOT OF ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITY TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
MEMBERS WE MET WITH THE PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND A. B. C.
SEPARATELY WHICH TO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CONDUCTING
OPERATIONS IN A FOUR PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WASN'T ABLE TO
TELL US. HOW. OPTIONS ENGAGED
THEY WERE WHERE OF STE.
EDUCATIONAL REYES AND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT BETTER BUT NOT AS A
ROBUST. SYSTEM AS WHAT WE FOUND
THE A. B. C. WHERE THERE IS
SOME OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
FORTY FIFTY THOUSAND STING
OPERATIONS CONDUCTED STATEWIDE.
AND SEEM LIKE A MORE THOROUGH
EFFORT. TO ENSURE THAT THESE
PRODUCTS WERE BEING SOLD TO
UNDERAGE USE THAT OUR STORES
NOW. I WALKED AWAY CERTAINLY IS
AS A CONSIDERATION FROM THOSE
MEETINGS THINKING THAT. WE MAY
WANT TO STREAMLINE SOME OF THAT
ENFORCEMENT I'M NOT SURE IT
MAKES SENSE TO HAVE A B. C.
HAVE OFFICERS AT THE SAME
LOCATIONS THAT WE HAVE TO PART
PUBLIC HEALTH. TRYING TO
CONDUCT OPERATIONS I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT I ALSO THINK THAT
IS A MAJOR UNDERTAKING. BEYOND
WHAT WE'RE ABLE DOING THIS BILL
BUT I THINK SOMETHING THAT
REMAINS ON THE TABLE FOR
DISCUSSION. AND PERHAPS YOU
KNOW THROUGH OUR BUDGET PROCESS.
EVEN THROUGH THE BILL LATER
SESSION WE MAY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO ADDRESS THAT
AND I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT WE
DO ADDRESS THAT THIS BILL
MANDATES A 20% TOTAL OF THE
RETAIL LOCATIONS TO HAVE A
STING CONDUCTED AND SO WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
PRACTICAL REALITY OF HOW. HOW
THAT GETS DONE WHAT YOU
REFERRED TO MR CARS A DIFFERENT
YOU NOW CALL. AND TOBACCO
REMAINS THE SAME AS WE FIRST
DISCOVERED YOU COULD SELL.
TOBACCO TWO HUNDRED USE I
BELIEVE FIVE TIMES IN FIVE
YEARS WITHOUT LOSING YOUR
LICENSE. CURRENT LAW FOR
ALCOHOL WAS THREE TIMES IN
THIRTY SIX MONTHS. WE HAVE
RECTIFIED THAT BROUGHT BOTH
STANDARDS DOWN TO THREE IN
THIRTY SIX IN THIS BILL BEFORE
YOU TODAY. AND THE PENALTIES ON
YOUTH OBVIOUSLY STILL EXIST IN
ALCOHOL WE CHOSE TO STRIKE THAT
FROM THIS BILL WHEN THE BILL
WENT TO JAIL COMMITTEE IS THAT
WAS AN AREA. THAT WE DIDN'T
FIND AGREEMENT AMONGST ALL THE
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE ON THE
HOUSE. THE ENFORCEMENT SIDE I
DO REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE AND
PERHAPS IN YOU KNOW YOUR
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN THE BUDGET
MAVIS CARTY AND OTHERS WE CAN.
START TO ENGAGE THROUGH THAT
PROCESS TO SEE THAT WE GIVE THE
TOOLS. THE IT TOOK PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH OR SOME TYPE OF
COLLABORATION WITH A. B. C. OR-
A REALIGNMENT OF DUTIES SO THAT
WE CAN EFFECTIVELY MAKE SURE.
THAT THESE RETAIL LOCATIONS ARE
IN FACT NOT SOUND TO YOU
BECAUSE THAT IS. ONE OF THE FEW
TOUCH POINTS AT WHICH YOU CAN
GAIN ACCESS TO SEE THEIR FROM
AN ADULT AN OLDER FRIEND ONLINE
OR FROM A RETAILER. YEAH AND-
THE FEES IS AN ISSUE I KNOW
WE'RE NOT DOING THIS TODAY AND-
I THINK WE OUGHT TO BE LOOKING
AT ESTABLISHMENT TO. TO PAY FOR
PROPER ENFORCEMENT. IT'S
OBVIOUSLY A VERY PROFITABLE
INDUSTRY. ON THE SALES WEEK I
ONE GOT GAS THIS MORNING AND I
TOOK A PEEK. AND IT'S- A MAJOR
ADVERTISING ON THE FRONT WINDOW
THE PROBLEM DISPLAY WHEN YOU
WALK IN SO THAT TELLS ME. THIS
PRODUCT MAKES A LOT OF MONEY
FOR THAT STORE. SO IF WE NEED
TO INCREASE THE FEE STRUCTURE
LICENSING STRUCTURE TO PAY FOR
THIS. WE SHOULD BECAUSE THAT IS
CLEARLY HOW YOUNG PEOPLE. ARE
GETTING THE PRODUCTS AND THAT'S
WHAT THAT THAT THE STING.
OPERATION THAT COMPLETE CNN
REPORTED ON A FEW MONTHS AGO.
SHOW SO. I'M ALL IN ON THAT I
KNOW THAT THERE'S OTHER
MEASURES COMING FORWARD
RELATING TO. ONLINE SALES WHICH
IS ANOTHER PROBLEM HOW YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE GETTING A HOLD OF
THIS. PRODUCT AND I REALIZE
THAT THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM
HERE THEY WERE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE BILL IS THE FLAVOR
ISSUE. STRONG OPINIONS. ON THAT
THESE FLAVORS ARE REALLY THE
HOOK FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND
THERE'S- POSITIONS THAT YOU YOU
KNOW. ARE CHICKS THEY OUT THE
TALKS ABOUT THE DOLLS MAKING.
DECISIONS BASED ON YOU KNOW HIM
BEING AN ADULT SO. WE WILL WE
WILL. EVALUATE THAT ANOTHER DAY
AND- THE ELEMENT THIS BILL
BEFORE PRESS. I THINK ARE VERY.
HELPFUL IN DEALING WITH THIS
EPIDEMIC SO. YOU KNOW THE.
GROUP THAT WE WORKED OUT A FEW
MONTHS AGO LAST WEEK SOMETIME
IN SUPPORT TO AND YOU KNOW WE
WILL TAKE. BY SOME COMMENTS AND
THEN ON OF GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE PROVIDE. I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH TAKEN THE
AMENDMENTS AND I'D I'D I DO
BELIEVE NOW WITH BILL
STRUCTURED IT IT DOES IT DOES
SOME GOOD THINGS AND I'M I'M
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
OBVIOUSLY HAD CONCERNS ABOUT
SOME ASPECTS OF THE BILL THE
WAY IT WAS ORIGINALLY WRITTEN
IT APPEARED. TO PREEMPTS LOCAL
ORDINANCES. IT DOESN'T NOW BY
STRIKING SECTION SEVEN AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
NOT HAVING PREEMPTION WE HAVE
THIRTY SIX AT LEAST THIRTY
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE
HAD SOME SORT OF REGULATION
AROUND THIS. SAN FRANCISCO HAS
BANNED E. CIGARETTES COMPLETELY
SAM SACRAMENTO IS NOW BANNED
FLAVORS AND COMING FROM A CITY.
THAT TRIED TO RAISE THE AGE
WHICH TOOK ABOUT. TWO TWENTY
ONE WHEN I WAS THE MAYOR IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND BEING
PREEMPTED BY STATE LAW WAS ONE
OF THE BIG MOTIVATING FACTORS
FOR ME GETTING BEHIND. THE BILL
THAT ULTIMATELY WAS PASSED DATE
THERE IS THE AGE TO BUY
CIGARETTES TO TWENTY ONE. SO
ANY PRE GEN FROM IS GONNA BE
WITH IT WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE. ALSO IT WE HAVE A
INDIVIDUAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
ALLOWED TO HAVE BACK RETAIL
BUSINESSES. THAT HAVE DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
RESTRICTIONS POTENTIALLY
COUNTIES CAN DO THEIR OWN STING
OPERATION CITIES COULD DO.
THEIR OWN STING OPERATIONS
SHOULD YOU CHOOSE TO IN THAT. I
ACTUALLY AM WONDERING WHERE MY
INVITATION TO WORK WAS I WASN'T
INVITED HIM WE CLEARLY HAVE
JURISDICTION HERE. I WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ON A REGULAR BASIS. I STOOD ON
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE THAT
DOES FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. SO I AM
DISAPPOINTED TO HAVE NOT BEEN
INCLUDED IN ANY OF THE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND THAT.AND I
WILL AGREE WITH MR MCCARTY THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM HERE IS
THE FLAVORS. THERE WAS A BILL
THAT WAS NOT HEARD THAT WOULD
HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS AND WE
COULD I STILL WELCOME A ROBOT
DISCUSSED AROUND FLAVORS. WHICH
I BELIEVE IS THE SINGLE.
BIGGEST ISSUE ATTRACTING KIDS
TO USE THIS PRODUCT. STING
OPERATIONS ARE GONNA BE
DIFFERENT DPH HAS THEIR OWN
UNIT A. B. C. HAS OUR OWN UNIT
THEY ARE SEPARATE I DON'T SEE
HOW WE ULTIMATELY COMBINE THOSE
BUT I DO WANT TO SAY THAT I A
WE ARE GOING TO WHAT I DO A
RECOMMENDATION PASSED THE BILL
TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS IN THE
FUTURE AND IF YOU CONVENE
ANOTHER STAKEHOLDER GROUP RUN
THIS ISSUE SINCE WE OBVIOUSLY
DO BOTH HAVE JURISDICTION I
WOULD APPRECIATE BEING A PART
OF THAT DISCUSSION. WHICH I.
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS WAS CHAIRMAN ONE POINT
A CLARITY THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE CLARITY. OF
SOCIALLY WHAT WOULDN'T LEAVE
THE COMMITTEE OR THE PUBLIC
WITH THE IMPRESSION. THAT YOU
WERE SOMEHOW EXCLUDED FROM THE
PROCESS THE WORKING GROUP WAS
OF AUTHORS OF BILLS THAT WERE
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE. BOTH IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THEN OF COURSE
OF OUR SENATE COUNTERPARTS. I
BELIEVE YOU MAY HAVE BEEN A CO
AUTHOR TO ONE BILLS AND- WHAT'S
HOUSE THE JOINT AUTHORS MR
JOINT AUTHORS. TO CARD IN
MISTER ARE DID PARTICIPATE AS
DID. SO LAWCENTER CAR PASSED WE
DIDN'T GET ALL OF THE CO OF THE
CO AUTHORS OR JOINT AUTHORS FOR
THAT MATTER IN EVERY MEETING.
BUT CERTAINLY. YOU KNOW THAT
GROUP DIDN'T INTEND TO EXCLUDE
YOU AND AS WE- OPEN UP A
WORKING GROUP TO THE LARGER
TOPIC WHICH I THINK IS. THE
CIGARETTES PART PUBLIC HEALTH
ENFORCEMENT. IT'S ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT THING AND I THINK THE
APPROPRIATE. COMMITTEE CHAIRS
BE INCLUDED WOULD INDEED BE
APPROPRIATE AND THAT WOULD BE
MY RECOMMENDATION TO INCLUDE
WORK WITH THIS COMMITTEE. IN
THAT CAPACITY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TOWARDS NEXT YEAR. BUT
IT TO THE WAS A POOR TO CLARIFY
THAT. APPRECIATE YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE DIFFERENCES
OF OPINION WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION IN. OUR
MEMBERS ISN'T THE NOTION THAT
WE NEED TO. ELIMINATE ACCESS TO
THESE PRODUCTS FOR YOU WHERE WE
DO HAVE A DISAGREEMENT IS
LIMITING ACCESS TO PRODUCTS FOR
ADULTS. RIGHT THOSE LEGITIMATE
YOUR MERIT MERITORIOUS
ARGUMENTS ON BOTH SIDES OF THAT
QUESTION BUT I THINK THE ISSUE
IS TOO IMPORTANT TO OUR YOUTH
WE DON'T KNOW FOR SOMETHING I
THINK THAT'S IN THE SPIRIT OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING. TODAY I'VE
STATED VERY CLEARLY THIS BILL
COMING INTO THIS. WAS FOR. NOW
IS NOT THE FLAVORS WE'RE NOT
NAY TIRE ALIGNMENT ON THAT BUT
I THINK RATHER THAN STOP. THE
PROCESS OF ALL THE OTHER
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THAT ARE
IMPORTANT AND COULD ELIMINATE
SOME OF THIS ACCESS IS PRODUCTS
WILL TO MOVE FORWARD IN
AGREEMENT ON THOSE AND-
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THOSE AREAS
WHERE WE HAVE DIFFERENCES SO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PERCENT THE BILL I APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT HERE TODAY.
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ON. THE BILL. I
WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I.
BUT. THANK YOU AND I AND I
APPRECIATE THAT I WILL I WILL
MAKE. ONE MORE COMMENT OKAY
CHAIR GETS TO DO THAT. AND THAT
IS WHAT WE DO HAVE A
DISAGREEMENT ON THE FLAVORS
PORTION OF THAT I DID NOT FEEL
THAT I WANTED TO PUT SOMETHING
IN STATUTE. THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
BE OF LESSER AFFECTED THAN
WHAT'S CURRENTLY BEING DONE BY
CITIES AND COUNTIES OUT THERE.
AND ONE OF THOSE KEY FLAVORS TO
ME IS MEANT AND WHILE WE
DISAGREE THAT AN EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLD OR A TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD
CALIFORNIA LAW IS THAT TWENTY
ONE IS THE LEGAL AGE.
UNFORTUNATELY MEANT IS ONE OF
THE MOST POPULAR FLAVORS FROM
THE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLD. AND THE THX AGE
GROUP. AND I IF YOU LIKE THE
STATISTICS WOULD BE HAPPY
PROVIDE YOU WITH THAT BUT IT IS
THE MOST POPULAR WITH THAT AGE
PARTICULAR AGE GROUP. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THIS THE FLAVORS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A HUGE ISSUE FOR
MOST OF US. I HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
THIS PRODUCT THE INDUSTRY
RECENTLY I BELIEVE HAS SUE THE
FDA. TO DELAY TESTING OF THE
PRODUCTS WHICH I FIND.
DISAPPOINTING TO SAY THE LEAST
IT FEELS THAT EVERY DAY WE SEE
A AN ADDITIONAL STORY ABOUT
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES WITH
RELATED TO THIS INDUSTRY.
INCLUDING MOST RECENTLY WHAT
STARTED OUT AS THIRTY ONE
PEOPLE WITH MYSTERIOUS
RESPIRATORY AILMENTS IS NOW
BLOWN UP TO TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
AND I SUSPECT THAT THAT NUMBER
WILL PROBABLY INCREASE AS
FURTHER REPORTS COMMENTS SO WHY
THE A WEEK CLEARLY HAVE A
PRODUCT THAT IS EXPLODED IN
POPULARITY. BUT THE HELL OUT
HEALTH EFFECTS OF THAT ARE
STILL VERY VERY MUCH QUESTION.
I AM DISAPPOINTED THAT THAT.
THE INDUSTRY WOULD PUSH BACK ON
THE FTA ACTUALLY DOING THE
STUDIES TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THIS LOOK AT THIS PARTICULAR
PRODUCT SO. WITH THAT WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY MR MAYES A
SECOND BY MISTER BIGELOW. AND I
WOULD ASK THE SECRETARY TO CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTIONS TO PASS
YOUR PREPARATIONS. WHEN I WOULD
AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BONTA
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE HI
CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA
AND THE MOLD MCCARTY MCCARTY I
IN THIS IN THIS AREA AND I'M
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO. WALDRON
WALDRON I. ZERO YOUR BILL AS
THIRTY VOTES IT'S OUT OF
COMMITTEE THANK YOU MEMBERS
SIGNATURE THANK YOU. OTHER
MEMBERS WHO MAY WISH TO ADD ON.
THIS IN A COUPLE OF PEOPLE. AS
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SANTA BONTA
AYE BURKE BURKE I LIVE ALONE
NAZARIAN. MISTER IS THERE IN.
IS THERE ANY TIME RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO WALDRON
WALDRON AYE. THAT'S IS IT
THIRTEEN ZERO SO WE IF MISSILE
MOAN AND MISTER SANTIAGO. I'D
LIKE TO COME AND VOTE WE WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
.
FINALLY IN PERSON. A COUPLE OF
THE
. WELL BEN SECTOR WILL CALL
OPEN THE ROLE CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AB SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE
GRAY. LIVE ON AYE SANTIAGO.
FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
OR SIX IS THE SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT A RUBIO PLEASE
OPEN ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THE MON. Là MON I.
SANTIAGO FOURTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU
. YEAH FOR THE DAY. YEAH HI.
YEAH. YEAH YEAH YEAH
. SEPARATE
NINETY. WELL. VERY MUCH. MUCH
FASTER. OKAY I ASSUME WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE ROLE ITEM NUMBER
ONE ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
THIRTY NINE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN ZERO AND THEN
ITEM NUMBER TWO SENATE BILL
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN ZERO SO THAT
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH